we're going to turn now to Atlanta where
a judge has released part of a special
grand jury report on efforts by former
president Donald Trump and his allies to
overturn Georgia's 2020 election results
the report shows that the grand jury did
believe the voting itself was legitimate
but the panel did not believe some of
the testimony it heard Robert Costa is
in Atlanta with more on this Bob good
morning
Good morning Tony this grand jury sat
for more than seven months and heard
from 75 Witnesses and it has concluded
that some of them might have lied the
brief document released yesterday States
a majority of the grand jury believes
that perjury may have been committed by
one or more witnesses testifying before
it it provides no names but went on to
encourage Fulton County district
attorney fonnie Willis to seek
indictments for possible crimes Willis
convened the grand jury and it heard
from many witnesses including longtime
Trump lawyer Rudy Giuliani South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham and
Georgia Governor Brian Kemp the
investigation centered around the
efforts to overturn President Biden's
2020 victory in Georgia and on that
point the grand jury was clear with all
the jurors agreeing that no widespread
fraud took place in the state the rest
of the grand jury's work remains private
including recommendations on possible
indictments but the district attorney
says decisions are imminent and former
president Trump he continues to maintain
that he has done nothing wrong Nate Bob
thank you